this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream use the link in the description
to watch thousands of documentaries and
at no extra cost
my 30-minute exclusive documentary about
Macau available now on nebula China is
one of only two countries whose
population sizes stand out so
dramatically from all the rest the fact
that almost a billion and a half people
are represented by one flag one
government and ultimately one person is
something everyone knows but very few
appreciate for its difficulty just how
does a country this big stay unified the
short answer is it's not China appears
monolithic because of its centralized
source of power the Communist Party and
its relative lack of ethnic diversity
ninety one percent of its population is
ethnically Han Chinese and all but one
other group comprises less than one
percent overall these small percentages
though in a country this big translate
to significant absolute numbers just as
important when discussing unity is the
concentration of these peoples a map of
China's languages or its ethnic
distribution paint a much more divided
picture very roughly speaking these
principally Mandarin and Han areas are
unified culturally the others from the
perspective of Beijing present either an
ongoing or potential inclination towards
detachment the abundance of these
regions is reflected in its complicated
administrative structure at its most
simplified China is first divided into
22 regular provinces like Szechuan
within which are prefectures like Wuhan
followed by counties townships and
lastly villages or communities in
practice there are quite a few
exceptions Taiwan for example is China's
claimed 23rd province for mega cities
including Beijing and Shanghai are
treated as provinces there are two
special administrative regions and
finally five autonomous regions Xin
Jiang Inner Mongolia Tibet squanchy
ningxia each for one of the country's
largest ethnic minorities only in two of
them however our Han Chinese
not the majority group in Xin Jiang we
girls make up forty five percent of the
population compared to 40 percent Han
Chinese and Tibet is 92 percent Tibetan
these two regions are similar in that
while they comprise only a tiny portion
of China's overall population they're
among its most strategically useful
Tibet is in fact its least populated
province with only 3 million people or
0.2 percent overall underneath it's
sparsely populated land however our
bountiful reserves of copper iron lead
potassium and other important minerals
the vast mountainous landscape also
protects the core of China from invasion
in the future it's most coveted resource
may become its water after the Arctic
and Antarctic the Tibetan Plateau
contains the world's largest source of
fresh water earning it the nickname
Earth's third Pole this is especially
important because of China's otherwise
poor water position more than a quarter
of its land is desert whose storms blow
dust into cities like Beijing many of
its rivers meanwhile are too polluted to
provide an adequate supply of water as
the world's glaciers melt and water
becomes increasingly scarce areas like
these could easily become the source of
state conflict but while Tibet and
Xinjiang are among China's most valuable
regions they're also among its most at
risk of detachment thus why it places
such high importance on cohesion at
times it's promoted unity by rejecting
ethnic differences linguistically for
example the Chinese term mean to refers
both to nation and ethnic group
implicitly denying a difference
other times cohesion has been promoted
by explicitly acknowledging differences
and then correcting for them all Chinese
national ID cards list their holders
ethnicity which since the reform
following the death of Mao has played a
significant role in a person's
opportunities and privileges minorities
were exempted from laws
like the one-child policy received
preferential admission to university and
may have an easier time securing loans
for instance finally in more recent
times cohesion has been forced in the
unfortunate form of violence the most
prominent example of which is China's
campaign to restrict the religious and
personal rights of Xin Jung's Muslim
Uighur
by placing as many as a million in
brutal so-called
re-education camps although Chinese
authorities claim their purpose is to
manage religious extremism the ultimate
goal is to pull the country's Geographic
and cultural edges closer and minimize
the risk of secession horrific as these
recent developments are they aren't
without precedent before assuming the
office of President Xi Jinping's
predecessor who Jintao served as the
highest ranked official in the Tibet
Autonomous Region during which martial
law was declared following a violent
crackdown on protests in 1989 later as
president he appointed a man named Chen
Tong go to his previous post in Tibet
there Chen gained a reputation for his
Swift uncompromising approach to dissent
and creating a vast system of state
surveillance in 2016 he was moved by
Xi's administration from Tibet to Xin
Jiang along with his oppressive methods
only now with the help of modern
technology
in other words Tibet is the model for
Xin Jiang there is however one major
difference His Holiness the Dalai Lama
while China's camps prompt international
condemnation
the issue lacks a recognisable face
Tibet presents a unique challenge to
China because the Dalai Lama is such an
admired charismatic leader after
remaining largely independence between
1913 and 15 the new People's Republic of
China invaded Tibet in 51 forcing the
Dalai Lama to recognize Chinese
sovereignty in 1959 fearing his safety
he fled in disguise to India where he
was granted asylum to this day although
the Chinese government maintains to
facto control over Tibet the central
Tibetan administration as it's known
continues to claim it its compound in
North India is now home to
community of over 100,000 Tibetans in
exile
although the Tibetan cause is not as
high-profile as it once was the Dalai
Lama regularly travels the world giving
speeches at universities granting
interviews and meeting with important
figures to evade the ire of Beijing
countries often frame these meetings in
religious not political terms when his
holiness visited the White House in 2016
it released a careful statement which
quote reiterated the long-standing u.s.
position that Tibet is a part of the
People's Republic of China notably the
meeting with President Obama occurred in
the White House Map Room not the Oval
Office inevitably though Beijing still
retaliates after David Cameron's meeting
in 2012 China froze high-level political
contact for nearly a year
although these events rarely lead to any
substantive progress they helped cement
his legitimacy and raise public
awareness the downside of having such an
influential single figurehead is that
heads are mortal the Dalai Lama was
hospitalised last April for a chest
infection which at 84 years old
naturally raises questions about what
comes next according to Tibetan Buddhism
the Dalai Lama has reached the ultimate
goal of breaking the cycle of births and
death but instead chosen to continue
being reincarnated in order to help
others reach their spiritual
enlightenment
the current Dalai Lama is the 14th body
in that 6th century long line
however because monks are celibate
succession cannot be hereditary when a
Dalai Lama dies a search must therefore
be conducted to discover the newly
reincarnated body this process can take
years and involves the reading of arcane
spiritual signs for example the deceased
body of the 13th Dalai Lama initially
lay facing south after a few days his
head had shifted to the east while a
fungus appeared on the northeastern side
of his shrine high Lamas interpreted
this as a sign the next body would be
found in northeastern Tibet where they
searched villages for newly born
children next a series of tests are
conducted to confirm a suspected child
the 14th Dalai Lama was presented items
for identification some previously owned
by his predecessor after allegedly being
able to correctly identify all of them
and receiving confirmation from scholars
he began relearning the knowledge from
his previous lives in preparation for
leadership clearly this opaque process
leaves plenty of ambiguity for China to
take advantage of and because Tibetan
Buddhism is not confined to Tibet or
China by managing religious traditions
it also wields incredible influence over
its followers around the world although
officially atheistic the Communist Party
does not hesitate to encourage and even
enforce religion when useful China has
spent three billion dollars developing
the site of Buddhas births in Nepal
built a Buddhist Center and Myanmar and
donated to the translation of Buddhist
texts likewise if it can use the
institution of the Dalai Lama to
influence millions it will gladly ignore
the irony in 2007 it passed national
legislation regulating reincarnation
under these new laws the party maintains
a database of officially sanctioned
Buddhas after training them to promote
ideological harmony most absurd of all
individuals are required to submit an
application for reincarnation to the
government for approval in 2011 new
ordinances were passed which station
party officials at monasteries for
direct supervision seeing the writing on
the wall the Dalai Lama then issued an
edict exploring the possibility of
selecting a child before his death or
spiritual transfer to a fully grown
adult he later added that his successor
may be born outside Tibet perhaps as a
woman and that it may even be time for
the tradition of the Dalai Lama to end
clearly he intends on leaving all
possibilities on the table by not
advocating Tibetan independence only
autonomy the Dalai Lama is a pragmatic
negotiator finally he resigned from all
political responsibilities thus
minimizing the potential damage of a
Chinese chosen successor Chinese
officials countered that such a decision
is not his to make that religious
precedent must be respected
since then China has reiterated its
position that reincarnation must comply
with Chinese laws while US officials
have stated that Congress would refuse
to recognize anyone chosen by the
Chinese government the Dalai Lama plans
on making a decision when he turns
around 90 in 2025 with every day the
chance of health failure rises as do the
odds of China appointing their
preference as they did in 1995 with a
second most important Lama when that day
comes
China may or may not be successful in
gaining the support of Tibetans but
without question the death of such a
personable icon will leave a huge hole
in the Tibetan cause and help bring
Beijing one huge step closer to its
dream of a single unified China Tibet is
only one of many border regions that
could pose a threat to Chinese unity one
though is different Macau like its
neighbor Hong Kong Macau is a small
Cantonese speaking former European
colony the two special administrative
regions are even neighbors and yets Hong
Kong fiercely protests against China
while Macau adores it why that's the
question I answer in my 30-minute
documentary available now on nebula when
you sign up with the link in the
description you'll get access to
curiosity stream home to thousands of
great documentaries on technology nature
and science but for that same price of
just 20 dollars a year you also get
access to our new streaming platform
nebula it's the only place you can
currently watch my new video along with
many other great originals and ad free
versions of the videos you watch every
day I've worked really hard on this
video and I think it's some of my best
work yet if you like my normal videos
this is much more of it in far greater
depth if that sounds interesting
please sign up with a link in the
description and you'll then get an email
with access to start watching nebula
thanks to curiosity stream for
sponsoring this video
you